good morning buenos dias thank you so
much for coming to our latinx in ai
science panel on diversity
gracias
de la
quinos
este
my name is julian pachon i'm originally
from colombia i'm a director and chief
scientist for amazon last mile
my team focuses on the development of
optimization and ai based algorithms to
plan the delivery of over 9 million
packages per year around the world
i will be your host for this session
my name is julia
colombiano
algorithmia
amazon science wanted to invite you all
as members of latinx in ai to
participate in a discussion with
different amazon science leaders
our panelists today will be sharing
personal anecdotes about their journey
through their career at amazon and will
be answering questions that you all have
submitted to us regarding diversity and
innovation
the goal of this discussion is to
provide an open forum conversation for
diverse members of the ai community to
learn about experiences opportunities
and challenges that exist from
science leaders
various leaders
so let me introduce you to our panelists
huerta is originally from mexico
one is a senior research manager in the
area of search and ai
we have darwin villagomes originally
from ecuador darwin is a senior research
manager in the area of bio-risk and
fraud prevention
we have ontario majoral cuevas he's
originally from mexico
while teddy is a principal research
scientist in the area of computer vision
and machine learning
and we have francisca gil loretta she's
originally from santiago in chile and
she's an applied scientist in the area
of imaging and technology so can i ask
the panelists to
introduce yourself and tell us a little
bit about your career path here in
amazon so juan why don't we get started
with you
sure
hola todos my name is juan juan guerta
i'm a senior science manager in the
search and ai team
and uh my team and i what uh what we do
essentially we build
large deep learning models to help
downstream uh machine learning
applications within amazon what it means
is that we take lots of data
and we train
as i said very large models using
distributed clusters
and
and then these models are used
to help other machine learning tasks
improve their their performance in terms
of in terms of my background um
my background is in electrical and
computer engineering um i'm originally
from mexico
and in my career i've been in different
roles in the industry i've been in you
know banking in finance
but i also did some research in speech
and nlp
before coming
awesome thank you darwin
uh hola todos
my name is darwin and i'm a senior
research science manager in the area of
consumer protection customer protection
and fraud prevention
i lead a team
that builds predictive machine learning
models to protect amazon customers from
hackers
so that means
we screen every time a person tries to
sign into amazon or place an order in
amazon trying to figure out if it is
really the person really the customer or
is a hacker trying to take over the
account
we screen more than 100 million daily
attempts to send in and place orders in
amazon and if we believe it's not the
real customer we try to stop the
transaction and abandon and to do this
at scale we use machine learning models
to determine the level of risk of the
event or transaction
a little bit of my background i grew up
in ecuador i got my undergrad and
master's degrees there then i moved to
the us to get me my phd in physics so
that's my my record in physics and i
transitioned to
when i transitioned to industry i
started working on the machine learning
piece on the military learning site
at amazon i'm principal research
scientist leading
the efforts of computer vision machine
learning for amazon's special projects
unit
in in this in this unit we think big
about how amazon can make an impact
that matters in the world and we have
launched several products that are
oriented to create benefits to as many
people as possible these include things
like
uh echo frames for example that allows
you to have artificial intelligence with
you
all the times
amazon care which is remote
telemedicine
to bring medical access to as many
people
as possible
amazon explorer which is like virtual uh
telepresence that you can go and visit
multiple places in real time
and also
in amazon globe my team is developing
computer vision to bring uh children and
their loved ones together independent of
of the distance
and a little bit of my background i
i did my undergrad degree at unam in
mexico which is a main national
university there and then i went to do
my phd in the uk and then i became a
professor
in the uk and amazon i have found this
very conductive because i i'm still a
professor in the uk but i can still
um help amazon
from from inside so i have this this
great ability of having contacts in both
academia and industry and that helps
both sides
thank you thank you
and francisco
hola my name is francisca i'm an applied
scientist at amazon i specialize in 3d
computer graphics and computer vision
i work designing algorithms to create 3d
models faster amazon we want to have 3d
models of pretty much everything we're
selling
so we need to
speed up the creation of 3d models and
that's where i work currently
before joining amazon i completed my phd
in computer science at nyu in new york
there i was working with 3d printers and
other digital manufacturing techniques
i'm originally from santiago de chile i
grew up there and did my undergrad and
master's degree in computer engineering
and then i moved to the us around 2011 i
worked as a developer in san francisco
for a couple of years before starting my
phd
so i've been in in the us for a bit of i
think 10 years and at amazon for two
years and a half already
awesome thank you francisca let's get it
started we have selected multiple
questions from the numerals that were
submitted by you all to be discussed in
this panel
so our first question is what is it like
to work at amazon in ai research
francisca you want to get us started so
i joined amazon right after my phd and
the experience has been pretty great for
me
i've gotten to collaborate with a 3d
artist with engineers and researchers of
very different backgrounds
and i like i really like working in
interdisciplinary teams because i i
learned a lot from everyone and i'm a
very curious person
and the day-to-day will vary depending
on the stage we are in a project uh we
do read a lot of papers a lot of the
state of the art to see how we can apply
it to our problems we have a lot of
discussions
we write code that gets into production
and we run a lot of experiments to
validate that what we're doing is
actually going to have a important
impact
so it's a bit of everything but every
part of the project it's very exciting
awesome darwin
yeah i've been with amazon for
almost six years now and i joined this
team
that that um
trying to protect customers from hackers
so
the focus on amazon is always the
customer and we built our models uh with
the customer in mind first
to make sure the customer is protected
and that i think that is uh
something i enjoy a lot
working at amazon all the research we do
is applied research it has a direct
impact on the lives of our customers
so we build
for example we protect customers from
hackers using a mix of unsupervised
supervised models normally detection
we borrowed
techniques from deep learning
or
other supervised and supervised
learning techniques
i'm also
very lucky to have a big support from a
good teams of engineers and scientists
that's the other thing that uh
i enjoy working with
at amazon is a collaboration between
different teams with that within the
objective
to feel
to fulfill that objective and to meet
those goals
we are constantly challenged to improve
the customer experience and balance
fraud prevention with customer friction
our predictive models have to run fast
so that's a that's a good challenge they
need to
gather all the information compute all
the features and run all the models very
quickly and they need to be very
accurate also
if we get it wrong
we can potentially cancel orders from
real customers or block them from
accessing amazon which is not acceptable
it is a good challenge to maintain this
balance balancing model precision and
recall is not a theoretical problem
anymore
but it has real impact on customers so i
think that's one of the
good challenges of working with a
company on the campus on the machine
learning side
awesome
uh juan
yes
in my case what i really enjoyed at
amazon is working together with uh with
scientists and engineers that are really
really good
um what in our case what we do is we
take technologies that are available off
the shelf both through you know aws and
open source like pytorch and
again um you know commodity hardware
right again available in aws
and use these to train our models and
many times what we need to do is we need
to create a specific
adaptations or code
right to adjust to our specific needs so
for example
you know processing of images
manipulation of text
so we develop those
solutions right that help us overall uh
model training
and uh we also write code that uh is a
little bit more um
help us stream high volumes of data into
these clusters of gpus so at the end uh
what we have is really a solution that
is a mixture of hardware uh software and
specialized uh technologies or solutions
or code that that we write so i think i
find that very exciting to work again in
these
multi-multi-disciplinary
teams awesome one thank you so much now
in the area of the last mile we have a
large number of ai based applications
in this area it is very hard to get
source of fruit
for a lot of the data that is used for
planning our operations around the world
so we actively you know do research in
ai
to improve our inputs for example we
plan
hundreds of thousands of routes per day
and so one key input to a planning a
route is service time and the service
time is the time that it takes to
deliver a package you know to my house
or to your house or to house somebody in
india but the challenge that we have is
that this time is different for every
house around the world and the reason
why is that in some houses you may have
the parking just in front of the house
in another one you may have a long
pathway
some customers live in an apartment
building where you actually have to take
an elevator to take the packages to the
doorstep of the of the apartment
so at the end of the day we have to
learn this for every single house around
the world where we deliver packages so
this is a you know obviously a very a
hard problem so we constantly kind of
you know use ar technology to be able to
learn from our previous deliveries and
being able to refine our inputs we do
this for you know transit times to
improve our maps to decide how to
consolidate stops and so on so many of
our scientists in my team have spent
their time
looking at your special concerts around
the world and finding ways to kind of
improve them on a you know ongoing basis
great well let's move to the to the next
question
and it is a what challenges did you face
at the beginning of your work in amazon
francisco do you want to go first
sure yes
so one of the challenges i faced was
that i wasn't very used to thinking of
the customer when working
and at amazon
were a very customer focused company
and i think a good example of what i
went through is that i spent i think
maybe three months working on an
algorithm
without ever talking with the 3d artists
who were gonna actually use the tool
i think i i didn't even demo it for
three months
so then i i show them
what i've done and they're pretty
excited with the demo they're like okay
this is super cool
and they also tell me like it would be
even better if you had added this stuff
and i had implemented that two months
ago it was one of the first things we
had implemented but we thought it was
too simple and we didn't saw the value
in it so we dismiss it
so after the conversation with the
artists i have to like go back and
re-implement that very first thing that
we had implemented
and
it was a
good experience for me to have and
it made me realize how important it was
to keep a continuous conversation with
our customers and to learn from them and
to take what their experience into the
algorithms that we're building and
that's something that i've been doing
since then it was very important for my
path at amazon
awesome
juan why don't you tell us a little bit
about your challenges
sure so what i found is that uh amazon
is very peculiar in the sense that uh
it's a very document oriented
organization what that means is that uh
when we have a meeting right
traditionally typically what we do is we
bring a document and we spend uh some
part of the meeting reading
and the rest of the time during that
meeting having a conversation on on the
document
um this is in contrast to what i was
used to before which was more visual
driven right having decks of slides or
power points with graphs and
bullet points
and uh it was an interesting transition
because um going from again the visual
power point presentation that you know
is essentially the presenter walks the
audience through the slides
versus everybody uh
reading separately and then having a an
open conversation around the document it
really changes the way um you know
you prepare for the meeting you have to
now prepare a document and develop the
thinking in a different way and also how
the conversation happens is also
different right
and what i really like about this method
is that it allows to develop the
argument uh
differently right as a as you're
preparing those documents for for the
meetings you you tend to think a little
bit differently in a way that you have
to express your thoughts again in
paragraphs and you know in more uh
i get i would say different ways uh from
the visual um but you know that that was
a different way of doing things and i
think that's uh pretty interesting
awesome thank you juan
well no i came to amazon from the
aviation industry and even though the
planning for aviation has a lot of
similarities on how we plan the last
month the scale is very different and
the largest challenge i think i faced at
the beginning of my career at amazon was
understanding that a great scientific
approach and to solve a problem may not
be the right path forward given the
growth rate of the amazon business and
i'll give you an example you know in
routing there are numerous and thousands
of publications you know about how
people have solved the routing problem
and there are many great approaches and
and many of them you know work for a few
dozen nodes a few hundred nodes a few
thousand nodes
but when you have to solve this problem
for two hundred thousand packages you
know on a particular day in a couple of
a minutes for a given city then you
really need to think about this problem
in a different way
so you know early on
i learned that in amazon scalability
matters a lot more than optimality and
you know all the approaches that we have
to put to the table have to be able to
scale to the growth of the business
otherwise you know they become you know
in a way invisible approaches
cool so let's go with it with the next
question and what is in your opinion the
most important skill a person from latin
america most developed to be successful
in ai
and data science and darwin
can i get started
uh yeah thanks for the question
i i believe that the foundation
for a successful career and machine
learning data sciences is that balance
between having strong technical skills
and also the ability to act and deliver
and communicate findings
now one of the
important things is to build those good
communication skills both in writing and
also in presentations as leon was saying
we
we're very
document based
companies so writing is is very
important communicate your findings we
are writing documents
but also in presentations
this usually means in english
and this is especially important for the
latinx community since in many cases
english is not our first language so
it's important to build that competency
with the language it doesn't mean to be
perfect
but it means being able to communicate
clearly
the other important thing is to keep
learning
and being curious
this is actually a skill that we need to
practice we all need to practice and
develop
to never stop learning uh new things so
our field changes a lot and challenges
us to keep
pace with technology so keep that
curiosity going is is very important for
your careers
awesome well teddy you want to give us
your view on this
sure no i actually agree quite a lot on
the on the two points that darwin has
just mentioned and i just wanted to add
in mexico we have a couple of phrases
one of them is nothikas which roughly
means
believing yourself
and another one which is nothing
chicopalis which is slightly different
and roughly it also means
that don't be afraid of making mistakes
and i think these two things believing
in yourself and don't be afraid of
making mistakes can allow you to succeed
anywhere but particularly in in the
latinx community
where we might have struggled to get
access to local mentorship or resources
sometimes we we over index on the fact
that we might not have uh what we think
we need or that
uh we don't we we don't have the skills
to to develop and i think this this is
very crucial to overcome so
uh it's super uh super important i do
believe that uh if you're going uh
anywhere you're going uh that that you
do believe in yourself and never be
afraid of making mistakes
thank you we'll tell you
okay well let's go to the next question
what advice will you give to a phd
student who is interested in joining the
industry ontario why don't you go first
this time
okay um so i think the first thing to
say here is that any career path that
you choose what really matters is that
you have to be passionate about
about that and if you're passionate
about that you're going to succeed
uh to join industry
uh you have to love
solving problems that other people have
and to do that with with constraints we
you really heard about what juliana and
everyone has said about uh having to
deal with with limitations
uh and if you think about that solving
problems that someone else has and do
that with me with with constraints
pretty much that applies to any career
path both in academia or in social
causes
so they are not that different from that
point of view so at the end of the day
what what really matters is that
that you have that passion to
uh to do what what you are doing
and uh the other thing i want to say
there is that as a phd student or as a
graduate student joining industry you're
going to bring a lot of of skills that
are very very important you're going to
bring not just the expertise in the
field that you are currently becoming an
expert on or already be an a worldwide
expert you're also going to come with a
lot of tools
that allow you to solve problems in a
specific scientifically oriented way and
that often matters more than the
specialization that you might gain in
the phd or or your masters what matters
is how you approach problems that you go
on and
and get the the right uh
papers to read and the right tools and
the approach of of succeeding and
failing and trying uh and and building
experiments all those tools are super
important so i i do think it's very
important for anyone from
uh from graduate school to learn uh as
good as possible those skills uh maybe
even more than than the specific topic
awesome
one what advice you have for our phd
students
yeah um so i agree with walter and
you know the way i think about it is
that there's a balance between
the depth and the breadth in the
knowledge right and typically a phd
student will spend many years
developing uh
depth right and expertise in a specific
problem and usually they come with with
a lot of depth in that specific area and
uh typically programs phd programs look
to
you know provide breadth or you know
make sure that the candidate or the phd
candidate has satisfies the breadth
usually in the form of uh like walter
said right training on or exposure to
different technologies things like that
or qualifying exams or you know taking
classes
um but um
you know when once so my advice is that
when the candidate comes to industry
right uh
keeping in mind that breadth in science
is important as well right and what does
that mean to have science breadth in
industry it really has uh you know a
might have a little bit of different
meaning for different uh companies right
so uh for for example in amazon
specifically my main you know exposure
skill sets in particular programming
tools particular technologies and and so
on right of course and algorithms and
you know the theories of machine
learning and the foundation the
foundations of machine learning and deep
learning
awesome hey francisco what is your view
on this
um yeah
what i'm thinking is that
i think my advice will be different
depending if you are starting your phd
or like wrapping it up if you're
starting the phd i would say i would
recommend to try to do internships in
industry
kind of to evaluate what walter was
saying like can you be passionate
working in that environment i think
internships will give you
they will give you first hand experience
on that
now if you are wrapping up your phd or
your postdoc
and you haven't done any internship or
don't have any industry experience
then i would suggest to to try to talk
with
people that have the job you want
basically try to contact previous
students or previous postdocs or like
shake all of your network
to try to talk with these people
directly and ask them type of the same
type of questions we've been trying to
answer here
to see if if you really see yourself
doing that type of job
and i would also suggest and maybe
similar to one fan was saying of
to see what you've done in the phd a bit
beyond the papers that you've written
to take a look at what other skills you
have developed
my bet is that if you've been working
with a lot of people
you've at some point led that people to
do something or at least organize them
to finish a paper or to work on a
problem and and those are skills those
are good skills that are needed in
industry
if on the other hand you've been working
mostly alone then you you probably know
how to
do independent independent research
which is also a good skill to have
so that's my suggestion like take
another look at what you've learned like
those skills put them in your cv
learn to talk about them learn to have
examples of
to tell us the stories of what you've
done
and that will also like help out in your
path in industry awesome thank you
francisca okay so we we talk about the
the phd students now let's move to you
know once you kind of graduate and you
have you know early career researchers
and engineers
uh you know that are interested in
working on amazon you know
darwin what will be
your suggestions for these folks on what
will be their focus on their
specializations
yeah when it comes to
the specific specialization
for a place like amazon amazon is is a
very diverse place in terms of
the
types of business applications that we
build
and the use of science for that
so there's a place um
to use the skills from different
specializations so i think there's no
bad choices when it comes to what the
specialization you're going to choose
for your phd
from supervised and supervised learning
it can be computer vision natural
language processing reinforcement
learning you can add many others i think
there's no bad choices because a company
like amazon
there's a constant need for
uh
for to build science applications on
that lot of
very diverse set of business problems
the
but it is important that you're able to
develop that area of expertise and one
one specialization but you also have to
complement that and balance that with
what
one was saying a good breath of
knowledge you have to know about this uh
what other fields and machine learning
and ai do and you have to keep a good
idea of that big picture of how these
uh fields are and industrializations are
linked
um
and how they're linked together that
will help you draw when you're actually
applying this and solving problems draw
from these other fields to build the
stronger applications
and also to
what what terry was saying and the
ability to actually take this
knowledge that you have
that
expert knowledge in one or two areas and
that breadth of knowledge and uh and
other aspects of machine learning and
actually translate that into
uh building using tools to build as
really is one of the most important
things that you can you can do in your
early specialization is is the
application of those um to move from the
theoretical
uh to actually building applications and
using these tools to solve to solve
problems
awesome thank you darwin
well we're coming to the to the last
question uh for today
and uh
we'll tell you you know that amazon does
you know a collaboration in research
with you know uh many research groups
around the world but let me ask you what
strategies specifically you think could
be adopted by both latin american
universities and amazon science to
foster collaboration in a research
project
yeah i know that's great question uh
then thanks i i do think the first step
is the obvious step which is to start
the conversation
and uh i have found that amazon is
fairly amenable to hear about
opportunities where
we might help so
the first thing will be to just hear
about
the opportunities the challenges that
you're facing
uh perhaps one thing to say here however
is that amazon is fairly scientific
which is a good thing i love that aspect
of amazon so we we love to hear about
what the potential impact of problems
and and solutions can be
but we are also very very keen on being
able to measure
the impact of that potential solution so
i think that that means that if you do
approach us and you can approach amazon
science directly
you can also reach out to anyone in this
panel i'm sure you will be able to find
us
in in linkedin and other places
uh
come prepared
when you when you have an opportunity
comfort with with a solution that is
measurable and that
you are identifying how you want to uh
to measure the impact so that it's
easier for amazon to understand both the
problem and the and the potential of
that of that challenge or
or problem that you're facing so i think
again
starting the conversation i also want to
highlight that amazon already has a
number of programs that are open
worldwide uh they include for for
example uh academics anywhere in the
world there is this program called
amazon scholars and amazon scholars
already has
at least one recent academic from from
latin america that has joined the
program and that allows academics
to engage with industry in a temporary
or semi-temporary
manner
that's that's really good
the other one is the aws credits which
allows you to apply for funding to use
cloud computing for
teaching or research
and then there is also
the amazon research awards which is
no strings attached money so you submit
a research proposal and if it resonates
from the point of view of of you're
going to push the boundaries of research
then you you can get funds to develop
that proposal and uh and and that is for
your own research amazon does not
necessarily um engage with with what you
do but of course it would be great if we
if we can hear about your impactful
research and that helps amazon as well
so there are a range of programs already
out there um i do invite any anyone in
the audience to to have a look at them
um
and otherwise just reach out reach out
to amazon science or anyone here in the
panel to to help somehow to channel
those
thank you so much walter well i want to
thank you all for attending our panel
today and thank you to the panelists for
sharing their experiences muchisimas
gracias participants panelists
for more information or if you like to
learn about opportunities at amazon
please reach out to lxai amazon science
at amazon.com
and also do not forget to visit
amazon.science website website
to stay up to date on real estate news
and announcements which is
[Music]
you